이 챕터에서는 프레임워크를 제공할 거야
컴퓨터 환경에 대해 생각하는 방식을
노트북에도 적용할 수 있고
슈퍼컴퓨터까지 확장할 수 있는
이 챕터가 끝나면
컴퓨터 리소스의 기본 개념을 이해하게 될 거야
그리고 서로 어떤 관계인지도
그럼 컴퓨터 리소스란 뭘까 간단히 말하면
컴퓨터 시스템을 구성하는 부품들이야
CPU, 즉 중앙처리장치가 있는데
대부분의 명령을 실행하고, 메모리도 있어
RAM이라고도 하는데 데이터를 임시로 저장하고
프로그램 명령도 저장해
그리고 GPU, 그래픽처리장치도 있어
그래픽 렌더링을 위해 설계됐지만
범용 컴퓨팅 작업에도 쓸 수 있어
대규모 병렬 처리가 필요한
과학 시뮬레이션, 데이터 분석, 머신러닝 같은 것들
이 리소스들은 함께 프로그램을 실행하고
각각 고유한 측정 단위가 있어
예를 들어 CPU는 코어 수로 측정하고
클럭 속도, 메모리는 바이트로 측정해
기가, 메가, 테라바이트 단위로
각 문제마다
필요한 리소스 세트가 있을 거야
그것들을 실행하기 위해
실행에 필요한 리소스를 고려하는 게 중요해
효율적으로, 프로그램 구성 요소가 실행되는 위치와
그것들을 연결하는 인프라의 대역폭이
중요한 역할을 해
전체 성능을 결정하는 데
예를 들어 GPU가 특정 부분을 빠르게 계산할 수 있어도
프로그램을 GPU 메모리에 로드하는 게
우리가 절약한 시간보다 오래 걸리면
CPU를 쓰는 게 더 빠를 수도 있어 이제
클래식 리소스 스케일링에 대해 얘기해보자
두 가지 방식이 있어, 수직 스케일링과
수평 스케일링 수직 스케일링은 늘리는 거야
단일 리소스의 성능을
더 강력한 CPU나 더 많은 메모리를 사용하는 것처럼
하나의 물리적 노드 안에서
노드는 여러 리소스를 포함하는 컴퓨트 클러스터의 단위야
수평 스케일링은
리소스를 추가하는 거야
여러 CPU나 GPU처럼
단일 노드나 여러 노드에서 함께 작동하도록
두 방식 모두 장단점이 있고
선택은 구체적인 사용 사례에 따라 달라져
새로운 유형의 리소스를 소개할게
양자 리소스, 양자 리소스는 양자 정보를 처리해
QPU, 즉 양자처리장치를 사용해서 QPU는
전체 시스템으로 담당하고 있어
실행 가능한 양자 명령어 세트를 받아들이는 것을
또는 quantum circuit을 받아서 반환하는 것도
정확한 답을 의미해
QPU에는 하나 이상의 양자 칩이 포함돼 있어
예를 들어 IBM 양자 시스템처럼
그리고 여러 추가 구성 요소도 있어
희석 냉동기 안에
양자 칩을 냉각하는
양자 증폭기, 제어 전자장치 같은 것들
그리고 필요한 클래식 컴퓨터도 있어
명령어 저장 같은 작업을 위해
파형을 메모리에 저장하고 결과를 누적하는 것과
미래의 오류 정정 디코딩도
일반적으로 양자 리소스는 측정돼
품질, 레이어드 피델리티 스케일로
qubit 수와
속도, circuit 레이어 연산으로
초당 CLOPS로 오늘은 양자 칩을
측정 단위로 취급할 거야 리소스 관리 시스템이
GPU를 코어 수가 아니라
전체 단위로 취급하는 것처럼 스케일링은 어떨까
클래식 리소스처럼 양자 리소스도 스케일링할 수 있어
수직과
수평으로 나눌 수 있어 수직 스케일링은
칩렛이나
칩당 qubit 수를 늘리는 거야
수평 스케일링은 칩들을
커플러나 클래식 인터커넥트로 연결하는 거야
이 정의를 알았으니
리소스 관리에 대해 얘기해보자
컴퓨터 인프라에서 리소스 관리란
계획하고
할당하고 컴퓨팅 리소스 사용을 제어하는 과정이야
CPU, 메모리, 스토리지처럼
네트워크 대역폭을 효율적으로
효과적으로 활용하기 위해서
리소스 관리를
다차원 테트리스 게임처럼 생각하면 돼, 블록은
작업 요구 사항이고
각 차원은 리소스 단위야 일반적인 작업은
이 작업 블록들을
사용 가능한 리소스 큐브에 맞추는 거야 리소스 관리는
매우 까다로운 작업이고 다양한 컴퓨팅 시설들이
각기 다른 전략으로 인프라를 구성해
사용자 기반의 특정 요구에 맞게
방금 배운 개념을 적용하기 위해
Slurm을 사용할 거야 Slurm은 오픈소스 소프트웨어야
리소스 관리를 위한
데모 목적으로
가상 노드 3개짜리 로컬 환경을 만들었어
컴퓨터 노드 정보를 얻을 수 있어
scontrol 명령어를 실행해서
두 개의 파티션 또는 노드 그룹이 있어
normal과 quantum normal 파티션은 노드들로 구성돼
클래식 리소스만 접근 가능한
quantum 파티션은 양자 리소스에 접근 가능해
먼저 간단한
클래식 hello world 예제를 Slurm으로 해보자
먼저 hello world 프로그램 자체가 필요해
이게 우리 프로그램이고 단순히 hello
world를 출력하는 거야
이제 리소스 매니저한테 알려줘야 해
이 프로그램을 실행하는 데 어떤 리소스가 필요한지
얘기했듯이 Slurm은 방법을 제공해
작업의 모든 메타데이터를 지정하는
셸 스크립트로
Slurm 전용 어노테이션이 있는
이 어노테이션으로 리소스 요구 사항을 지정할 수 있어
스케줄링 파라미터 등을
제출 스크립트를 확인할 수 있어
여기서 파티션 명세,
필요한 노드 수, 노드당 태스크 수를
실행할 거야, 태스크당 CPU 수도
그리고 어떤 스크립트를 실행할지도
이게 우리 hello world 프로그램이야
작업을 실행에 제출하려면 명령어 하나만 실행하면 돼
sbatch 명령어야
스크립트를 인자로 제공하면 돼
실행 큐를 확인할 수 있어
우리 hello world 프로그램이 실행 중인 걸 볼 수 있어
normal 파티션의 노드 c1에서
작업이 완료되면 결과를 확인할 수 있어
출력 파일을 보면 돼
이게 다야
양자 리소스도 사용하고 싶으니까
간단한 hello Qiskit 프로그램을 만들어보자
여기 우리 Qiskit 프로그램이 있어, 모든
필요한 단계들이 포함돼 있어 circuit 생성,
최적화, 실행, 후처리
그리고 여기 우리가 얘기한 모든 프로그래밍 개념들이 있어
quantum circuit, transpiler,
Qiskit primitives도
이제 제출 스크립트를 만들어야 해
전처럼, 하지만 여기서는 지정해
양자 리소스 요구 사항을
리소스를 지정했으니
클러스터의 파티션도
어떤 양자 리소스가 사용 가능한지
Qiskit primitives가 사용할 거야
할당된 리소스로 양자 작업을 실행하기 위해
이제 프로그램을 실행해야 해
작업이 완료되면 결과를 확인할 수 있어
여기 기댓값이 있어
리소스 관리는 이게 다야
다음 섹션에서는 얘기할 거야
프로그래밍 모델에 대해